apprendre à swinguer en deux heures
c'est la promesse du golfe le saint
quentin en yvelines la structure propose
jusqu'à fin septembre des initiations
gratuites en partenariat avec la
fédération française avec ces baptêmes
la structure espère casser les préjugés
quand les gens ne connaissent pas du
tout ils disent que c'est un sport on va
dire entre guillemets de vieux que ce
n'est pas un sport déjà pour certains et
qui sont vraiment je dirais agréablement
surpris par ce qu'ils découvrent
lorsqu'ils font l'initiation
après un premier briefing d'une dizaine
de minutes les golfeurs en herbe
répartis en groupes de huit personnes
adultes et enfants sont lancés club à la
main dans le grand bain sous les
conseils d'un professeur un débutant se
pose plein de questions dix mille
questions c'est pour ça on essaie de
faire le plus simple possible
on essaye au maximum de ne pas parler
technique de parler vous avez vu j'ai
parlé de lancer ces faut faire simple le
plus sain possible c'est à dire les gens
ils se battaient technologies tic au
gîte écologique et a pu voir qu'il faut
taper il faut jouer il faut swinguer
faut se libérer
après une heure d'initiation premier
verdict le plus difficile c'est vraiment
le mouvement naturel parce que quand on
quand on quand on est avec le club et
quand on est avec la balle on a tendance
à vouloir forcer
alors que non faut pas forcer donc c'est
voilà c'est trouver le mouvement naturel
du golfe
alors moi je préfère le green les
mouvements douceur le petit balancier en
douceur parce que c'est vrai que le
swing c'est pas facile moi je me plante
dans le dans le sol au départ voilà donc
j'ai à progresser je crois à la fin de
la session entre 25 et 30% des golfeurs
débutants passe le pas et décide de
s'inscrire ils débourseront entre 750 et
1000 euros pour une année le prix pour
devenir peut-être un jour le futur tiger
woods